we have really good capacity for
bringing talent in and so for most
businesses Talent is the constraint of
the business the entrepreneur can only
do so much and that's kind of the issue
and so anything that's senior and up we
will directly recruit for them because
then also for us from a hold code
perspective if I've recruited half the
leadership then I have a really good
pulse of what's going on and I have good
Affinity with the leadership in that
business that we help build so it helps
us from a transparency perspective we
also know what this role looks like when
it's right one of the biggest issues
that entrepreneurs have in my opinion
when they're scaling is that they're
like oh here's my aunt she said she
could be our sales director she sold at
Sephora which is great no knock on
Sephora but she probably doesn't know
how to run a sales team we know what it
looks like we know how to interview for
it because ideally what we try and do is
build the team around the entrepreneurs
such that the entrepreneurs are required